headpieces people wear head pieces and
you know we saw the Pope's hat and
clearly that was just stolen from the
Pope but you have things like Frances
McDorman or this I don't know I don't
know how she gets cell reception with
that thing
that's the same looking this was from
the Valentino collection which literally
was a collection that made me cry it was
so beautiful um and the most exciting
part of that was she walked up to me
while we were waiting to do the steps
the red carpet and she was like I love
you you are wonderful and I was like
dying and then she took off the hat
scratched her head put it back on and
walked away
yeah just for that long just we're
nothing because it must be painful must
be awkward
yeah painful I want you to here you are
with scissor way back and I love recess
and you what's happening here because
Joe we took a selfie together and I
don't know if you can tell but that
beautiful headpiece she has on was so
sharp on the ends and my she when our
selfie she like caught on to a tuft of
my hair and I was like Oh God so when a
photographer came over to take a picture
I was like I'm not falling for that [ __ ]
again you can see you can see in the
photo that you're desperately I was like
I will not lose an eye not even for said
that it does look like if [ __ ] broke out
and people start like a brawl started
scissor could just start swinging their
head around absolutely
you could get behind her and she would
get you that would get on her back yeah
and we would go and you would just go we
would go yeah
you